no mi devi guardare cioè te lo giuro
sulle mie TN non lo conosco non ti calmi
ci buttano fuori abbiamo pagato €40 ce
ne sono ancora due drink capito vuoi
buttare tutto all'aria così ma ce la fai
ha visto quel tipo che mi hai guardato
un po' troppo e mi sa che sia un mio ex
poi li conosci tutti i miei ex Kevin e
pusher di barriera Jonathan quello che è
stato dentro per tentato omicidio eh
Christian è tatuatore Ma come non te
l'ho detto ma vero fai Oh ti chiami
Christian l'hai fatta tutore no Vedi sei
storto si chiama Marco fa l'università
Ma ti pare che esco con uno che studia
Ma sei scemo ma mi ha guardato perché
sono figo potresti essere contento che
ti guardano la tipa Ah sì Allora torna
con quel ci sta a pedali della tua ex e
vedi che non fai più risse in discoteca
come stavo fosse un cibo male invece sei
solo un cieco che avevamo Non fare così
Non piangere mi fai piangere pure a me
Dai Oh lo sai che amo solo te oh da
quella prima volta che ci siamo visti in
questo posto di merda che mi hai
limonato e ho capito che non ce n'era
più per nessuno Madò cosa non ti faccio
stasera amo andiamoci a bere sti due
drink